my fights in Japan were no weight  classes before everybody how much bigger  was 65. yeah for the guy 265 how much  seven 207 against 265. 60 pounds so  weight doesn't make that much  you don't want to get hit you know but  so but you slip you you know you make  sure you don't get hit people always  said well I never had an eight count I  never went down I never was knocked out  you know and they said so you don't like  to get hit I said I don't mind to get  hit but why would I let myself get hit  if I can't avoid it I mean it's simple  right so just to clear the air I don't  like getting hit right is that what  you're saying no I said nobody likes to  get hit I don't mind to get hit because  I know I have a hard head I mean they  broke no they hit a Coca-Cola bottle  like a big one on my head and it didn't  break I didn't go down you know baseball  bat with a nail in it it didn't go down  nunchuck I didn't go down so I I know I  have a hard hat